that's pretty good I see what we're
doing now let's go let's dance my top
three driving songs I'm going to go with
I follow by iiki I I
follow I follow you deep sea baby it's
something about that in a fast car that
make you want to go faster I would drive
to you
say hey hey it's called hey hey I like
that one the song called Love and Death
by EO Taylor I just love the horns I
just love the way that the engine and
the horns go together it's like a wal
when you play that song Flex up by
Future and this song XYZ on my new album
note Fury I will go Bob Marley Exodus
you know but the the windows got to be
down for that one maybe like Eric beef
for president you know just where you
just feeling fresh and you might have
the top down and you just you know the
seats back a little bit so those are a
[Music]
few